schon jetzt fordert der klimawandel
millionen tote durch hitzewellen
krankheiten und unterernährung werden
immer mehr menschen opfer
und selbst hier in europa werden wir
nicht verschont in den gemäßigten
breiten hat der klimawandel auch schon
bereits hunderttausende umgebracht und
der co2 gehalt in der atmosphäre der
steigt immer weiter
trotz der immer effektiveren
anstrengungen zur reduktion der co2
emissionen die bisher kaum beachteten
folgen des klimawandels hunger hitze
krankheit und wo der klimawandel die
meisten menschen umbringt jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
der sommer 2003 war die hölle und zwar
hier in europa temperaturen über 40 grad
celsius waren keine ausnahme sondern der
standard und über 37 grad also über
unser körper temperatur wird es
gefährlich 70.000 menschen starben
damals schätzungsweise und das in europa
weltweit sieht es nicht anders aus aber
schlimmer und seit dem jahr 2000 macht
das inzwischen millionen tote aus dass
wissenschaftliche medizin magazin the
lancet veröffentlicht dazu jedes jahr
ein report seinen countdown health and
climate change report der über die
gesundheitlichen folgen des klimawandels
berichtete human comedy direktor des
institute for human health and
performance am university college in
london hat an der studie mitgewirkt
zitat wir spüren gerade erst die ersten
auswirkungen des klimawandels wir müssen
sowohl die symptome als auch die
ursachen des klimawandels bekämpfen
zitat ende und die auswirkungen sind
schon jetzt dramatisch hitzewellen wie
2003 und auch 2015 sind dabei die
größten risiken seit dem jahr 2000 sind
125 millionen menschen alljährlich
solchen hitzewellen ausgesetzt gewesen
2040 werden es wahrscheinlich eine
milliarde menschen jedes jahr seien die
folge jedes jahr sterben millionen
menschen am klimawandel am schlimmsten
betroffen dabei die unterernährten
menschen in afrika und asien ihre zahl
ist seit 1990 von 398 millionen auf 422
millionen gestiegen und auch das ist
eine folge des klimawandels die ernten
gehen zurück ein grad höhere
temperaturen weltweit bedeuten zehn
prozent geringere reis und 6 prozent
geringere weizen ernten die
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
die an der studie mitgearbeitet haben
rechnen mit großem hungerkatastrophen
zusätzlich führen die hohen temperaturen
auch zur vermehrten chronischen leiden
nierenerkrankungen diabetes nehmen zu
und auch infektionskrankheiten breiten
sich stärker aus die größte
infektionsgefahr geht dabei von dengue
fieber aus die überträger die
gelbfiebermücken breiten sich immer mehr
über den globus aus und haben die
übertragungsraten seit den 50er jahren
um knapp zehn prozent steigen lassen
der klimawandel scheint immer schwerer
zu stoppen zu sein die
weltwetterorganisation wmo berichtet
jetzt dass die co2 konzentration in der
atmosphäre weiter steigt obwohl der
ausstoß weltweit in den letzten drei
jahren nicht gestiegen ist die
konzentration ist jetzt so hoch wie
zuletzt vor drei bis fünf millionen
jahren und damals lag der meeresspiegel
10 bis 20 meter höher
grund ist zum einen natürlich dass der
co2 ausstoß einfach zu hoch ist um den
co2 anteil in der atmosphäre sinken zu
lassen und zum anderen an wetterphänomen
die aber auch in dieser starken
ausprägung auf den klimawandel
zurückzuführen sind el niño war mit
seinen erhöhten ozean temperaturen und
dürren 2016 extrem stark durch das
veränderte klima konnten ozeane und
wälder weniger co2 aufnehmen als sonst
zitat die zahlen lügen nicht wir stoßen
nach wie vor zu viel aus und dies muss
sich ändern
das sagt der chef des un umweltprogramms
unep erik solheim es muss also dringend
dafür gesorgt werden dass der co2
ausstoß nicht nur stagniert sondern auch
verringert wird nur so haben wir die
chance die zahl der opfer einigermaßen
zu begrenzen ansonsten drohen weitere
aber und abermillionen tote schauen wir
also mal ganz genau auf die
koalitionsverhandlungen in berlin
ob da der schuss gehört wurde ich bin
gespannt wenn ihr kein video zum thema
und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesse nicht den auf
die glocke ja und hier geht es weiter
mit klimawandel bewiesen skeptiker
endgültig widerlegt also wenn
irgendjemand noch zweifel hat ohne
argumente sucht das video ist pflicht
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran